this is Sky News infighting pressure
from the back benches and even talks of
an attempted coup the tension within
government's High there's so much to
talk about this week and we're better
than on this show where I interview
people who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
[Music]
good evening this week the Prime
Minister took to the stage in Birmingham
to speak to both her party members and
voters with labor commanding huge leads
in the polls it appears the public have
taken a look at the conservatives under
Liz truss and don't much like what they
see her message this week that she
understands what voters are going
through and she's on their side
I have delivered in very difficult
circumstances for the British people we
have a plan and we need to get on and
deliver it
after he was forced to abolish his plan
it was a mistake to introduce the top
rate of tax the only one we saw from the
chancellor just then was a plan for
growth they want the prime minister to
commit to lifting benefits by inflation
not earnings the case of politicians you
must take your own side with you what's
your message to MPS and infighting what
would you like to say to them
this is surely the worst start of any
prime minister let's remember what we
were facing four weeks ago we were
facing we were facing
families having energy bills of up to
six thousand pounds
[Music]
[Applause]
priorities for
is for growth and growth
is trying to project strength from the
people in the room seem to like it but
she herself acknowledged this has been a
difficult few weeks if you like the
party prime minister
[Applause]
well tonight we hear from one formatory
donor who has since stopped his
donations to the party and has now
become a member of the labor party I
spoke to businessman Gareth quarry a
little earlier Gareth thanks so much for
joining us on the show today now you're
a successful entrepreneur you're married
to Jill you're also a father of four and
in this interview when we get a bit
along I'm going to talk to you all about
your backstory and how you came to be as
successful as you are but what I'd like
to start off with today is why we're
here why you're here you've been a
conservative voter all your life I think
you were a conservative party member at
times were you that's right you were a
conservative donor you've given tens of
thousands to the party under David
Cameron and then Theresa May and then
you stopped what what happened
I think it was a gradual realization
that the inequality in this country has
got ever more marked and I do think
sitting here today I think it's more
marked than ever before
and I just couldn't sit by being in a
very privileged position you know I have
got very lucky in business I have made a
lot of money and I could not sit by and
just watch that happen
and so the turning point was
May leaving and Johnson arriving and the
realization that some politicians are
only in it for themselves and I had to
therefore do a very radical thing which
will no doubt make me a pariah in a
number of areas but you've got to do the
right thing well come on to the radical
thing you did but just to go back to
Johnson and this being a turning point
this was a politician who spoke about
leveling up who brought together a
coalition of red wolvel voters as well
as the more traditional home county
voters of the conservatives he raised
taxes to put money into the NHS was he
not your type of Tory because if
anything he was on the center ground
wasn't he Boris Johnson yeah I think the
problem with Boris is his entire life
from what I've read he's gone about
getting what he wants a significant
amount of which is about personal Boris
aggrandizement
so it was Boris Johnson's not brand of
conservatism necessarily but his his set
of values that made you switch off from
the party yes that's when I wrote to the
party High command and said if that's
going to come to pass and this was
before he got in but it was clear the
direction of travel if that's going to
come to the Past then I will remove my
funding
and Gareth was that also because you
would say you are a one nation pro-eu
conservative that that is the wing of
the party that you sat on and that Boris
Johnson somehow went against that was
was his brexit credentials something
that really bothered you yes I mean this
is a man who had two speeches in his
pocket one fatal weekend and he selected
the leave speech I suspect largely
because it got him into number 10 on a
pretty guaranteed basis again you can't
take fundamental decisions for our
country which will bind our country and
impact our country for generations to
come you can't base that on what I
personally want to achieve so yes I did
vote remain but I absolutely accept the
Judgment of the country I'm not sure
something of that magnitude should have
been done on a straight
simple majority if you think about it
any in corporate life anything of that
significance would have a have to have a
slightly higher bar than 50.1 percent
but
those were the rules that's what was
decided and so we live with it you might
have disagreed with David Cameron on
holding that referendum and but you
didn't stop you didn't stop supporting
the party because of brexit it was
because of Boris Johnson yes yes um and
I had conversations in a very small
group over a dinner with Cameron before
he went to Germany to try and get you
know what he wanted to get as the best
interest of the company country to try
and get the vote through and he assured
me don't worry Gareth Angela's going to
give me uh what we want well but and I
asked him direct David what if she
doesn't don't worry Don't You trouble
your little head she will do you think
he was arrogant or complacent yeah the
Tory party is Riven with arrogance and
complacency this is totally out of touch
what I'm trying to get at is do you
think that that
Cameron was lackadaisical and complacent
about
the gravity of calling that referendum
and he just thought it won't happen I
can win it I just need to to do this for
internal party reasons and he was
arrogant about it without question but
that's what we've been dealing with for
many a long year now the schisms within
the Tory party most recently been played
out now with truss uh and kwaiting the
decision the Schism in the Tory party is
just we are jumping to the tune of
trying to keep the factions of the Tory
party Happy a hundred thousand people
put trust in place on a an agenda which
she's now saying is the is her mandate
for the country no it's not a very small
percentage of the population voted to
put you where you are let's go back to
the radical thing you did because your
parents or party members as a boy you
canvas for the conservatives you're a
party member you've always voted
conservative you were a donor you
donated tens of thousands of pounds then
you stop being a donor but not only did
you fall out of love with the
conservative party
you are now a member of the labor party
that is quite a journey how on Earth
did that happen I believe
the labor party under starmer and his
colleagues is a leftist center clearly
left quite rightly left of center
Alliance and
so that in many respects is the ground
the Tories
claim to have at one stage but
definitely no longer do so actually yes
I've shift I've tacked marginally to the
left but it's not such a dramatic change
and you
not only joined labor but you attended
the Party Conference in Liverpool
presumably you'd been to a number of
Tory party conferences as well had you
hadn't done that I've never been I had
been invited and I had never gone so
you'd never gone you went to labor what
was that like for you was it it was
lovely I mean it was
a bunch of incredibly friendly people
who so I should clarify Jill my wife is
a lifelong labor supporter so she's
never been to conference but she's
always she's brought up in Wolverhampton
she's always been
um a labor support you you've donated
hundred thousand pounds to the labor
party join me with Jill that's
International that's a lot of money
um we've been very lucky in business so
in the scheme of things it's just a sort
of note we should do and you know we
need to put stuff back and the
mismatches I see it between the funding
of the two main parties is a Big Driver
at that
in terms of that what does what do you
get for that I mean do you get to meet
kirst armor do you get to go I mean with
the conservatives there was we can get
on to this but they would have special
dinners for donors what I've never met
Kirsten what'd you get for that you get
nothing nothing there's nothing I want
I just want there to be a right-thinking
government in this country and if I can
play any part in that financially and
also I hope increasingly non-financially
you know I'm a businessman I mean most
well a lot of the left-wing party of the
labor party labor party think
businessmen are the devil incarnate
um I don't think that's right but of
course a lot of businessmen think that
the labor party is
the bad old Corbin foot whatever which
again is demonstrably not the case so if
I can contribute any way and lend a
voice then
I owe it to give it back to the country
and as a businessman let me just I just
quickly want to ask you about the mini
but I don't want to dwell too much on it
so I want to talk about you and your
family too but you're a successful
businessman a hugely successful clearly
what was your immediate reaction to that
mini budget were you surprised about the
market reaction
no because I think increasingly there is
there are two things at play here I
think one there is a recognition that
um
there needs to be change
and therefore people historically who
would have liked all those Sops to the
rich the rich themselves are saying oh
this this cannot happen so the a big
part of the U-turn was driven by the
rich saying no completely wrong
um and I think secondly there is so can
I just interrupt you you presumably
would have made a lot of money from the
45 Pence I can't I don't know I'm not
going to ask you what your income is but
you presumably I assume you pay taxes in
a fair way and pay your fair share of
income taxes you don't try and do tax
avoidance you would have made a fortune
from that yeah of course billions of
pounds not Millions hundreds of
thousands of serious serious amounts of
money hundreds of thousands of pounds
over a period of of you know the life of
a parliament yeah absolutely and also
the other thing you want that no look
if I can't pay more than my fair share
as a rich guy what hope is there I have
to I have to carry a greater burden on
my back because there are people out
there who over the last
15 years have not seen any change to
their lives and they are in Despair and
then we also have people who are on
benefits Etc who are now facing the
prospect of a cut in real terms people
like me have to be caned and caned
further you know this this corporation
tax again I'm a massive beneficiary of a
cutting Corporation tags but what is the
point no I couldn't give as a
businessman I could not give a toss
whether corporation tax is 19 or 25 so
you you felt that this sort of idea of
compassionate conservatism that was part
of Cameron's agenda and then actually
Theresa Mage remember she talked about
just about managing the jams the just
about managing people she talked a lot
about wanting to help them you felt that
in this budget that that that was
forgotten totally I mean Bankers bonuses
um obviously the u-turn on tax
corporation tax not taxing the utility
companies I mean what's all that about
this whole Kamikaze budget should be
withdrawn next week earliest opportunity
everyone's back in Parliament withdraw
it but what about the cotton and I
National Insurance for people or they
can't bringing forward the cotton income
tax
I can see that well I think there is a
purest school of thought that that
shouldn't happen at the moment that
there are even greater priorities than
that but I know that will make me
unpopular with everyone but there are
other ways you can deal with that with
those on higher incomes yeah I think
it's farcical that I get a cut in my
base rig attacks that's that's
ridiculous
um and then the sort of tiniered
approach to Bankers bonuses I mean
uh what's where's the logic apart from
the fact that these people and the sort
of energy companies who paid a million
to Boris these are all part of the
constituents in the back pocket you are
in a way going against your
self-interest and some of the things
you're talking about you are you know
saying I want to support an a party that
will probably tax you more potentially I
mean I don't know what kirstama's tax
plans are he certainly indicated to me
in an interview that he thought we
should look more at wealth taxes so
taxing dividends and shares more
um
lots of your friends who are business
people that maybe vote conservative of
you has this created a rift between you
and other people
no not a rift I mean I think there's
there's a respect for the view I've
taken there are the vast majority of
people are saying I totally understand
why you've done it I won't be voting
conservative
and not yet persuaded that I will go to
labor but I'll listen to you Gareth
um but that is the virtual Universe I'm
no one no one from my Tory mates has
reached out and said you're mad okay
well let's go back to why you became a
party donor in the fast food like why
did you do it why did you think I want
to put I mean I think it's about 75 000
pounds that you gave to the
conservatives again a lot of money why
did you do that
um because I was con very concerned in
the run-up to brexit and I was fighting
like mad to see if we could stay on our
preferential we've got the best of all
possible worlds
um so that was a big driver so you want
to try and try and at least get in the
room to make it make make an argument
yes
um but uh obviously that was you know I
made my arguments um I but
unsuccessfully and I was going to ask
you what I mean I know a little bit
about how it works because about the
kind of tiered system that the
conservative had but it does if you give
us a certain amount of money you get
access don't you to the prime minister
at dinners and events can you can you
tell the viewers about that because for
lots of people out there they won't
understand how it works okay so there
are various tiers
um of which the two top then it may have
changed now
um were linked to the amount you gave a
year
um and the second tier got you
um cabinet ministers uh coming to have
lunch with you either in Westminster or
in a club somewhere and they would stand
on their pins and say everything in the
garden's Rosy and we need to do this and
then there would be a sort of planted q
a
um I never got a queue
um but they were planted you know the
Great and the good were allowed to ask
one question each after lunch
um there was also higher tier
um which is called I don't know what
it's called
um which was for those who gave a
materially higher amount a year and that
got you yes access to Cameron I was
invited to some of those events and I
went to some of those events which were
small round table usually a dinner
um when it would follow the same format
but it would go on for longer and
because alcohol was involved um be a bit
more relaxed
when you look back on it now do you
think that's right that that should
happen I believed in what the party a
wing of the party was trying to do I was
despairing of Corbin I mean I'm afraid
there was a lesser evil than the you
know than Boris and that was sorry a
greater evil and Boris and that was uh
Corbin so
um I wasn't looking for influence do I
think it's right no in an Ideal World
um there would be no private funding of
parties but
I think that's very difficult to police
where do you draw the line there's lots
they're going to be lots of gray areas
well I wasn't funding I just did this
for them Etc so but I agree in an ideal
world because
sorry in an Ideal World yes private
private donor funding of political
parties would be removed what about
Union funding well that's that's the
flip side because you couldn't take the
private funding away from other parties
and allow the unions but of course
there's a question mark about Union
funding and at the moment as I
understand it I mean I just the reason I
ask is and and again viewers might not
know this but of uh the 2019 general
election the conservative party
donations accounted for just under
two-thirds of all donations 19.4 million
pounds the labor party got 5.4 million
of the conservative donations 13 million
were from individuals 5 million from
companies labor got 160 000 from
individuals two hundred thousand from
companies more than 5 million from trade
unions so you could look at it and say
well the conservatives are in the
pockets of wealthy individuals and labor
are beholden to the unions
that's the clear and inescapable logic
of those numbers
um that obviously doesn't make them
right and I think we need to have that
reformed that that will take time just
one other question on this the
chancellor meeting hedge fund managers
on the day of that mini budget do you
think there should be an investigation
into that meeting yes I mean a very at
the very least
it doesn't smell great
now I'm just going to come on to you now
you've made Millions as a businessman
you set up a legal recruitment firm
how how did you how did you take that
path I mean you did that when you were
41 years old you could have retired you
then set up another company
um
I've just been lucky I mean one of them
you've mentioned Jill my wife one of the
biggest pieces of luck was meeting her
day one at Cambridge
we were two lawyers out of seven
um she was from Wolverhampton I was from
Bedford
um
and we didn't we didn't go out to
Cambridge or indeed for two years
afterwards but we ended up living next
to renting houses next door morenti
Flats next door to each other one road
apart in balham gateway to the South and
um got together to have dinner and got
together
uh and then married
um in 1990 and then in 1998 she joined
the first recruitment business I had set
up she was a partner in a law firm and
she was doing an awful lot of work for
our company we were paying City partner
rates hourly rates
um and she said look I'm a bit bored of
Lord why don't I come and join you in
the business so we've actually worked
together day in day out in the
businesses since 1995. and Jill you know
you had four children you're very very
wealthy she always worked she didn't
have to but she always worked yeah I
mean Jill Jill made partner at 27.
that's unbelievable for any sex
uh in the city in a law firm she's a
phenomenally able bright
um woman with enormous capacity
um we knew we wanted to have a tribe of
children
we always absolutely shared child care
and if she wasn't here she would say
yeah I mean you know one of the kids
were sick then it wasn't the default
that it was Jill who wouldn't go to work
I had my own business I could be and
needed to be as flexible so you know she
got from a state school to Cambridge
given you know we're talking about State
School educations
um she got from State School to
Cambridge red law made partner at 27 I
mean her career has always been every
bit as important as mine so she's been a
mom
she's worked hard she's a role model
presumably you've got your three
children your four children your three
boys and and your daughter love day and
I I hope you don't mind me asking you
about this but a few years ago uh love
day suffered at the hands of cyber
bullies she was just 16 and she was
doing her she said do you mind telling
me what happened
um
if loveday was at an all-girls school a
really good all-girl School in Surrey
and
um because she had three older brothers
has three older brothers she's always
been fairly out there she's used to
dealing with boys and then she went to
an all-girls school
um
but she was still very out there and
still very outspoken and still if she
saw something unjust happened to one of
her friends particularly at the hands of
a boy
um she would shout about it and
remonstrate and get involved
there was a boys school completely
directly next door to her school
separated only by an iron chain link
fence and the boys at that school a
small handful of them uh decided that
because love day was not a size eight
and not what they saw as feminine
Perfection aged 16 they made her life
hell
and this was at a time when there was a
lot of experimentation going on with
social media they derided her for her
size
and
unsurprisingly because social media
is is a very cruel Beast what happened
what happened with love dated she did it
get worse for her then yeah she missed
her she missed most of her lower six and
upper six right
she still got into a great University
she's going to Exeter but coinciding
with a relationship ending just as she
went to Extra
she then went completely off the rails
and we ended up
um sitting in a mental health ward
locked
with the first set of doctor having
signed the papers for her to be
committed and we sat there waiting for
the second doctor
to arrive and I have to say it as a dad
seeing seeing your daughter go through
that is
intolerably hard that must have been
absolutely awesome and I I found it very
difficult
to talk about it to enunciate it
um
because blokes don't
and it got to the stage where Jill had
to be in loveday's room in University in
her first year sleeping in the room to
stop love day doing
bad things what hearts in ourselves yeah
um and that's where we ended up then at
The Priory
um waiting for the second doctor to come
along to section her
fortunately during that three-hour wait
love day
something changed in her mind
um and I
I don't know how she would describe it
and when the second doctor came along
and asked exactly the same question to
you the first question is loveday if
your parents and I were to leave the
room now what would you do and the first
doctor was told I will kill myself oh
by the time the second doctor had left
us stewing for three hours love day said
I need to go back to University I've had
enough of this and the turning point was
something I think very well I believe is
the turning point
if you're in
a room like that the threat to yourself
the bathroom door is not a door it's a
half swing door
and love day being the proud girl she is
she looked at that and said well where's
the bathroom door
and the doctor said well given what
you've just told me I can't leave you I
can't leave you so she said well okay
well the nurses be if else I do
um and will it be
female nurses and again she got the
answer we can't guarantee what sex the
nurses will be and that was I don't know
whether it was that
um but
there was just a sea change in Attitude
my final question for you just in terms
of love then and the knock-on effect
about social media for the minds of
young men and young women the
government's online harms safety bill
was introduced this year
do you think social media companies have
a responsibility to protect people like
your daughter or do you think it's more
about education of young adults to
understand what behaviors are acceptable
online or is it a mix of both
I think it's a mix of both the second
will just take a very long time because
it's not just young adults I mean it's
older people as well who just have a
very very strange attitude whether it's
to the opposite sex or to another race
or whatever
um so I think it needs to be both but
fundamentally
those involved in those Industries have
an obligation to cure the problem and do
it very very quickly on pain of
company life-threatening finds that's
the only message they're going to get
maybe that's a policy labor might change
if they do get into government at the
next election but
Gareth thank you so much for coming in
and I'm really glad that love day is
is better and doing some really exciting
work it's really great so thank you so
much thanks for coming to talk to me
today was a real pleasure to meet you
thanks Adam thank you thanks a lot
well that's all for today's show and if
you scan the QR code on your screen
right now you can listen to the Beth
Rigby interviews podcast a new episode
available now each week I take a look at
the highlights of the interviews and
there's some extra bits in there too
that's on the Sky News app or wherever
you get your podcasts thanks so much for
watching thanks to our guests and I'll
see you next week
[Music]